[Music]
welcome to water's world i'm jesse
waters the jig is up for joe biden his
credibility's shot the president's
approval rating hitting a new low of 43
percent as his failures keep piling up
in afghanistan joe left americans behind
he's covering this up this whole hostage
crisis still taking orders from the
taliban the commander-in-chief launching
a hideous drone strike that hit the
wrong target killing kids instead of
isis murders up everywhere biden's crime
plan failed
inflation's wiping out our wage gains
the recovery is weak and biden hasn't
crushed covet he promised to unite us
but his mandates are dividing us france
pulled their ambassador russia hacked us
to pieces and opec told joe to take a
hike when he asked him to pump more oil
and now even biden's beloved mainstream
media is admitting there's a problem
it has been a tough week for president
biden he's got a a pretty big
credibility crisis on his hands because
all of these problems in some ways
showed up after he said
something basically the exact opposite
what he has done so far yeah hasn't
really worked
but that's not all the crisis at the
border worse than ever before and biden
is blaming a broken system
yeah he broke it no wall no remain in
mexico just let everybody in
the del rio bridge in texas filled with
thousands of illegal haitians all week
third world conditions garbage sleeping
and dirt in a hundred degree weather
suffering babies it's awful
biden let thousands of haitian migrants
into america and flew some back to haiti
a few migrants biting ice officers on
their flight home
liberals in the media pushing a fake
claim that border patrol agents there
were whipping haitian migrants in del
rio after these photos were released the
story was debunked within hours these
were the horses reigns it's clear in the
video and the photo
but the horse whip hoax was pushed by
mad maxine waters no relation who said
this was worse than slavery
what the hell are we doing here
what we witness takes us back hundreds
of years
what we witnessed was worse than what we
witnessed in slavery
cowboys
with their reigns again
whipping
black people
al sharpton got in on the race hustle
flew down to texas and screamed about
slavery but patriots in texas were
having none of sharpton's race-baiting
lies
nobody wants to hear your racism
even the photographer who took the
photos said it was all a lie
paul ratchet saying i've never seen them
whip anybody with a thing he was
swinging it that's something that can be
easily misconstrued when you're looking
at the picture
and that's the point the left wants to
mislead with a fake crisis to distract
from the real crisis they created down
there
so the biden team puts the agents on
desk duty banned the use of horses in
del rio and launched an investigation
into this stupid hoax
a former border patrol horse coordinator
says it's going to be hard for them to
do their job now
the horse is a great tool
we've used for almost 100 years now and
and with that gone it's going to be
harder to patrol that area when people
look at what they're doing and interpret
another way it's it's it could be
frustrating no we don't we don't have
whips we don't carry whips and they they
weren't whipping them it was just a form
of
a pressure release the horses uh were a
little reluctant to uh
do the job that the uh agents were
asking and uh you know it's a twirling
the reigns uh was a just another tool
they used to to get the horses to do
what they're asking
joe biden pretended to take
responsibility for the whole border mess
but then passed the buck and pushed the
hoax watch
do you take responsibility for the chaos
that's unfolding of course i take
responsibility i'm president but i was
horrible with the city as you saw to see
people treat it like they did horses
barely running over people being
strapped it's outrageous i promise you
those people will pay
president biden's a disgrace he's either
lying or his handlers don't show him the
facts
he triggered this surge of illegals then
attacks the border patrol for trying to
control it
this is straight up anti-american
president's words and actions are
despicable and he should be ashamed of
himself
meanwhile his buddy chuck schumer says
we need to keep the borders open
because we need cheap labor
we're short of workers from one end of
america to the other one of the reasons
the trump administration dramatically
cut back on immigrants in this country
we need them
we need them in our labor force biden
created a labor shortage by handing out
free money and slapping mandates on us
then invites cheap illegal labor to fill
the gap
this is just what democrat donors want
and just what the democrats want too
because it turns texas blue
so just like afghanistan joe biden was
warned about the crisis at the border
and did nothing
border patrol union emails from june
reveal agents predicted this surge and
were begging for more help
but joe biden ignored it
biden doesn't want anything to do with
this he hasn't been to the border not
now or maybe ever it turns out fox's
peter ducey pressing gensake about it
has president biden ever been to the
southern border i will have to get look
back in my history books and check the
times he's been to the southern we have
been looking all morning and we cannot
find any record of him visiting the
border i can check and see when the last
time or when he may have been but but
tell me more about why you're asking
because this is a president who makes a
point when there are disasters in this
country like a wildfire or
a hurricane to go and see for himself
firsthand
what the needs are of the local
community so that he can have informed
pov to make policy
joe's not fighting for us
he's swamped by problems he created
and lies and hides when the pressure's
on
this is a failed presidency and there's
no telling what biden will do or say
to save it hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else